Hello and welcome back to
another exciting episode
of Game On!, our show
for game developers.
I'm your host Todd Kerpelman.
I know it's been awhile
since our last episode
and I've missed you.
Did you do something
different with your hair?
It looks nice.
Anyway, this episode
is all about not
shipping broken games.
Or I guess to put a more
positive spin on it,
testing your game
for fun and profit.
Mostly profit.
And it's all done through the
magic of using Google Play's
alpha and beta services
to get your game out
in front of a large
audience before you publish.
So I'd like to start
today by telling you
a little story about Don.
See Don is a game
developer and he just
released the very first version
of his hotly anticipated game
to the world.
He was so excited, he could
barely sleep that night.
And so when he woke up the next
morning, the first thing he did
was go out and check his
apps review page, which
looked a little
something like this.
Huh?
What happened?
Well, Don did some
digging around
and he found out that due
to a font rendering error,
the game crashed for any player
who had an E in their name.
Well Don immediately
got together
with his team members, Alicia
Winkowski, Irwin Lin, and Chris
Fulbright and said,
how did we miss this?
How could we have possibly
overlooked something
as completely obvious as--
OK, wait I think I see it.
None of us have
an E in our name.
That's kind of a problem.
That's when he
thought, huh, maybe we
should have tested this with
a bigger group of people
before we launched this thing.
But of course, that sets up its
own share of problems, right?
How are you going to
be sharing your game
with several dozen friends
and family members?
Are you going to be
mailing APKs around?
How are you going to make sure
that only these people have
access?
How are you going to
make sure that they're
looking at the latest version?
Do you have to mail them and
bug them each time you update
and hope that they then download
and resideload your APK?
Come to think of it,
how are you going
to teach your
nontechnical users how
to sideload an APK
in the first place?
It can be a bit of a mess.
And that brings us to one of the
best features of the Play Store
publishing process
that some of you
are overlooking, which frankly
is a real shame because it
was built for just
this situation.
And that is our Alpha Beta
Staged Rollout process.
Also sometimes
known as Alpha Beta
Canary because that makes
for a better looking acronym.
This lets you easily test
out new apps and app updates
with large groups
of people before you
publish to the world.
So let's see what this
process looks like.
Now in the past
you're probably used
to just uploading your
APK into production,
where it gets published
to the Play Store
and is available to the world.
And hurray, there's pixie dust.
Or I suppose, if things
go badly, uh, oh my god.
Everything's on fire, run.
One of the two.
Not sure.
But you don't have to do that.
So hang on their buddy, stay.
You see, the
Developer Console also
lets you specify a
certain group of people
to be your alpha testers.
This could be a Google group
or a Google+ community.
For example, for my first
group of alpha testers,
I might want this just to be the
employees in my organization.
So I could publish-- so I
could define my alpha testers
to be this group and then
publish my APK just to them.
Now assuming that all
goes well and we haven't
found any major
bugs, I could then
create a second group of
beta testers, maybe people
outside my company.
And again, publish my
APK just to them next.
Kind of similar
process as before.
Now, as for how this
looks to your testers,
you're just going to send them
a link to a page where they
can click on a button
to become a tester.
And once they do that,
they can download the game
from the Play
Store just as if it
were a completely normal app.
No weird sideloading involved.
Access is completely handled
by your group settings.
You can leave it open or
invite only, however you want.
And all those concerns Don
had, they're basically solved.
So where do you
get these testers?
Well, here's one fun example.
The developers of CastleStorm
promoted their Android program
right on their site.
So when you went and
visited their website,
you would see this page, click
on this little green Play
Now button, took you
to their Google group,
which was open for
anybody to join.
And they got a ton of great
beta testers this way.
But don't forget about
your Google+ communities.
These are often highly
engaged fans of your game.
And they'd be really good
candidates for beta testers.
Not only for any new
updates to existing games,
but also for any new
product that you release.
And by the way, this
is a fantastic way
to connect with your community.
Getting early feedback on
new games or new updates
from your most dedicated
fans will provide you
with some fantastic insight from
people who quite frankly know
your game probably
better than you.
And it also makes them part of
the process and a collaborator
in your game.
And then they can become
your biggest supporters
and your biggest advocates
in the outside world.
Your players, they want
your games to be awesome.
They're on your side.
Don't be afraid to
engage with them.
However you do it, assuming
everything goes well
with your beta
test group, you're
going to push wrap
up to production.
And then the world can
finally play your game.
Now this is all great,
but what happens
if you want to update your game?
Maybe you've got a
round of bug fixes,
but you want to make sure this
bug fix doesn't accidentally
create a whole bunch of
bigger bugs in the process.
It's been known to happen
to some game developers.
Quite possibly ones in this room
giving presentations right now.
So as you might
expect, alpha and beta
works similar for
game updates as well.
I can upload a new
version of my game
to the alpha group and
all my alpha testers,
they'll be able to grab the
latest version I have just
as if the app have been updated
normally for them in the Play
Store.
In fact, in many situations,
your alpha testers
will just get the
update automatically.
And then from there, I promote
my new version of my app
to beta, have my beta testers
try it out and then push it
on to production, right?
Well, wait, stop,
stay there one second.
See this time around, for
updates to an existing app,
there's a shocking twist.
Yes, that's right.
Even our stock image
photography model is surprised.
You see, instead of just
updating my app fully
on production, I
can do something
that's called a Staged Rollout.
What this lets me do is push
out the new version of my game
to just a small
percentage of the market.
This is a great way
to make extra sure
your game is going to work
well with a larger audience.
It also turns out
is a nice way to see
what people who aren't
your friends and family
might think of your game.
Turns out your mom
might not actually
be your most objective customer.
Sorry, Mom.
So what this means is I can
have Version 2 of my game
out to a small fraction
of the world while having
Version 1 of my game
available to everybody else.
And then as time goes
on and I'm feeling
fairly confident
about this update,
I can expand that rollout
more and more and more
until the whole world
is finally ready to see
the update to my game.
And the nice thing
is that you can
see your reviews, your crashes,
and your other stats broken out
by application version right
there in the Developer Console.
So if your players
hate your update,
you can see that right
away in the reviews.
More importantly, you can
also set up your own analytics
to be broken out
by version number.
So you can see if there are any
major problems with retention
or ARPDAU or ARPU
or any other custom
metrics you happen
to be tracking.
For instance, if we find out
that nobody is completing
the tutorial in our v2
release, well that's
a sign that something
is really wrong there.
And we can fix that before
we push this update out
to the entire population.
So this all sounds great right?
Well, with that said, let
me address three responses
I've heard from developers
around Alpha Beta testing.
The first is, well
I'm not sure I
want to use this because I
don't want to miss the chance
to be a "Top Recent" game.
And let me explain to you
what the concern is here.
So imagine that you spent a lot
of time with your game in Alpha
and then Beta test stages.
Then you're game
hits production here
and that's when it takes off.
Well, do we qualify as
the "Top Recent" game?
We have spent a couple of
months in Alpha and Beta.
And it's actually true.
We used to start the
"Top Recent" time here,
when your game first pushed
to Alpha, which I think we all
agree makes no sense.
So you'll be happy
to know we now
start the "Top
Recent" timer here,
once your game has been
pushed to production.
So if you hear of anybody who's
still afraid to Alpha test
because they're worried they're
going to miss their chance
to be on the "Top
Recent" list, let
them know we've
addressed this issue.
They're working on
old info and they
don't need to be concerned
about this anymore.
And in fact, what I'm also
excited to tell you-- and go
grab your business
analyst person
and tell them to
watch this part--
is that we are now calculating
the "Top Recent" list
per country.
So if you want to launch
your product in say, Canada
first and then launch two
weeks later in the US,
your "Top Recent"
window in the US
will be determined
by the time you first
launch there and not in Canada.
And so you can launch
in different countries
at different times and
not worry about missing
the "Top Recent"
window elsewhere.
See, your business analyst
person, they're really excited
now aren't they?
They're glad you grabbed them.
So a second question
I sometimes get
is how do you add achievements
or leaderboards or game
services-- other game services--
to a version of the game that's
in beta?
And it turns out these
days it's pretty easy.
When you create a new
leaderboard or achievement
or quest or event or what have
you in Play game services,
it remains in an unpublished
state on our servers
that's only visible
to your testers.
But if you go into the testers
portion of the Play Services
Developer Console,
right here, you
can see that you can easily add
alpha or beta testers as part
of the group that has access
to these unpublished features
on our servers.
So if you're new APK has say
a new leaderboard and five
new achievements, you can simply
publish that updated client
to your Alpha group.
And then, give those
same alpha testers access
to this new achievement
and the new leaderboard
and achievements on the server.
Your testers get to test
these new services out
and then the general public will
see this mystery leaderboard
or these mystery
achievements that they
can't seem to access or unlock.
A third question I
sometimes get is, OK,
so is this what I should
be using for A/B testing?
And my answer is kind of, sort
of, but not really, it depends.
Don't be confused by
these A/B letters.
Alpha Beta testing is different
than the split testing people
sometimes refer
to as A/B testing.
The point of Alpha
Beta Canary testing
is really to find
out if there are
major problems with your
game before you launch.
Now you could certainly
use it to find out
if you've accidentally
broken your in-game economy
or if some new feature
has improved retention.
But if you're looking to A/B
test small interface changes
or gameplay tweaks
or the wording
that you've put in
your purchase dialogue,
it's not really best for that.
You don't want your users
constantly downloading new APKs
and using up their
data plan every time
you want to test some
minor gameplay tweak.
So instead, I highly
recommend looking
at tools like Google Tag
Manager, which basically allow
you to configure your game and
run all the A/B testing you
want in the cloud.
Google Tag Manager is
a really great tool.
I am a fan, but I
probably don't have time
to talk about it here.
I'll have to cover that
in a future episode.
So with all of that in
mind, Don, our intrepid game
developer, got into his
handy dandy time machine
and went back in time to the
week before his game launched.
This time, instead of just
testing his game in house,
he decided to launch it on the
beta channel to several dozen
of his closest friends.
And that's where he found
and fixed several other bugs
that got missed by
his three person team.
With those bugs fixed,
he launched his game
to great fanfare.
The reviews were way up.
And just a few months
later, his company
was acquired for $12 billion.
Not because of the game
though, but because of the time
machine.
Turns out those things,
they're really valuable.
Anyway, if you are not in
the time machine business,
but you are in
the game business,
I'm hoping I've convinced
you at this point
that Alpha Beta
Canary testing is
something you should be doing.
It's generally pretty
easy to get started with.
It's all part of the
Play Developer Console.
But if you want to
see a walkthrough
or see me record a screen
capture or something,
let me know in the comments.
I'll do that.
So that's it for this Game On!
episode on testing your app.
Thanks for tuning in.
Test your games with your
family and friends and fans
and let's start seeing
some great games out there.
Bye.